je venais williams bonjour bonjour alors
vous êtes candidat sans étiquette sur la
circonscription numéro une la première
circonscription celle du centre vous
êtes conseiller municipal du robert et
vous êtes pour vice-président de cap
nord qu'est ce qui motive votre
candidature
ce qui me motive c'est mon action et mon
engagement politique depuis neuf ans
bien que non encartés je m'inscris dans
cet engagement au service de la
population et aux services des
martiniquaises et martiniquais je
considère que les difficultés qu'ils
rencontrent doivent être résolus et je
m'engage dans cette résolution leur état
d'esprit êtes vous parce que vous êtes
quand même soutenu par le maire du
françois celui du robert et vous est
également soutenue par pays acp
vous êtes confiant vous dites en vous
rasant que vous avez vous pouvez gagner
c'est la population qui décidera ces
soutiens je les prends avec gravité bien
évidemment avec plaisir mais en
responsabilité parce que ce sont des
gens qui sont aux responsabilités ce
sont des gens de terrain et qu'ils ont
confiance en moi qu'ils ont confiance en
mes orientations et celle de mon
suppléant jean lannoy donc je le prends
avec une grande responsabilité
quels sont les deux ou trois projets que
vous avez pour votre circonscription
mais aussi pour la martinique dans sa
globalité tout à fait il faut parler de
la martinique en globalité et nous
parlerons aussi de la circonscription de
manière plus précise
mais orientation elles sont nombreuses
un mais si je dois aller réduire un mât
3 je dirai évidemment la réduction de ce
fléau que constituent les sargasses je
parlerai aussi concernant la
valorisation de ces métiers des aides à
la personne aide à nos seniors sur les
sales gosses il faut que l'un que l'état
s'implique davantage il faut que l'état
prenne ses
responsabilités il faut qu'on parte sur
de la prévention plutôt que de la
réaction est aujourd'hui bien que l'état
ait mis en place certains dispositifs
ils sont insuffisants et la population
continue de souffrir les leviers
législatif existe des solutions existent
et je serai là pour les mettre en oeuvre
quelles sont encore les autres projets
je vous ai parlé de la valorisation de
ces métiers métier d' aide à la personne
pour savoir que la martinique en 2030
sera le territoire le plus vieux de
france et nous devons penser au
bien-être de nos aînés nous devons
penser à leur santé nous devons penser
aussi et bien à ce chômage qui pullulent
notre pays et grâce à cette
revalorisation de ces métiers de l'aide
à la personne nous allons pouvoir allier
les deux les solutions existent
certains parlent beaucoup de lutter
contre la vie chère pour vous c'est
aussi un vrai problème c'est un problème
c'est un problème qui national et en
particulier en martinique pour plusieurs
raisons parce que nos retraites ne sont
pas suffisamment revaloriser parce que
la martinique est l'un des territoires
où il ya le plus de chômage parce que
certes nous sommes loin mais tout de
même il y à des mécanismes de prix qui
nécessite une véritable étude et je
dirais une enquête parlementaire si vous
êtes élu ou allez vous siégez je suis
résolument un homme de gauche ce qui
veut dire que bien entendu je me
situerais à gauche mais aujourd'hui
n'avons pas de boule de cristal pour
savoir ce qui va advenir des groupes des
coûts parlementaire contre gauche nu
peuvent annuler sans nuque vous avez
nippes et composé de plusieurs groupes
donc à la suite de ces élections nous
verrons ce qui va se passer moi je serai
dans un groupe qui permettra aux
parlementaires des antilles de pouvoir
s'exprimer de pouvoir être entendue je
ne serai sur la coupe de personnes mais
j'agirai en conscience et avec ce groupe
pas pour le groupe mais avec ce groupe
et surtout pour la martinique alors
dernière question qu'avez vous à dire
aux électeurs pour les convaincre de
voter pour vous moi je leur dirai que je
suis une élue de terrain cela fait neuf
ans que je suis en politique je leur
dirai que je suis soutenue par des
hommes et des femmes de terrain je leur
dirais qu'aujourd'hui ça suffit qu'il
faut ce renouvellement que nous
attendons je ne suis pas un théoricien
de la politique je suis ancré dans mon
territoire je suis ancré dans cette
circonscription et je me battrai
jusqu'au bout pour eux et avec mon
suppléant aux gens là moi je venais
williams je vous remercie merci à vous
[Musique]